hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis
the world is on course to add as much
Renewable Power Generation in the next
five years as it has done in the last 20
that's according to new analysis
and a un Chief warns that we are at war
with nature and that's ahead of the
cop-15 biodiversity Summits in Montreal
and campaigners are calling on the
government to increase hedgerows by 40
by 2050 to boost wildlife and farming
foreign
welcome to the Daily climate show as I
said there we're tracking the changes to
our world and investigating some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now as I said earlier on the
world is on calls to add as much
Renewable Power Generation in the next
five years as it has done in the last 20
and that's according to new analysis
that's come in a report from the
International Energy agency says energy
security fears caused by Russia's
invasion of Ukraine have motivated
Nations to increasingly look at
Renewables such as solar and wind to
reduce Reliance on imported and
expensive fossil fills now this means
Renewables could overtake coal that's
the main source of global energy in the
next five years
now Renewable Power capacity is now
expected to grow by 2 400 gigawatts
between 2022 and 2027 an amount equal to
the entire power capacity of China today
and that expected increase is 30 percent
higher than the amount of growth that
was forecast just a year ago and reports
also found that Renewables are set to
account for more than 90 percent of
global electricity expansion over the
next five years so overtaking coal to
become the largest source of global
electricity by early
2025. what the chief executive of the
global wind energy Council Ben buckwell
joins me now Ben it's great to have you
with us on the program have you been
surprised looking at the reports by
these latest findings
um hi Vanessa thanks for having me on
um no I'm not surprised and um in fact
we have raised our own forecast as well
in the wind industry I mean what we're
seeing is much bigger government targets
um around the world in a higher ambition
and I think that's what we're seeing
reflected in this report and that's not
surprising given everything that's
happening with the energy crisis with
fossil fuel volatility uh with the
invasion of Ukraine um you know we fully
expect to see this and higher growth in
the coming years and are there any
particular countries that stand out to
you
well
um I guess the the good news is that the
very big countries the US and China
um and India leading this according to
the ie's research and again that's
that's how we see things
um I guess the bad news is that
everywhere else needs to speed up as
well
um and I think to put a slightly
different light on this I mean we will
get to for our industry over 100
gigawatts a year of wind energy uh next
year we were hoping to get there this
year
um but that's still only about a third
of what we need to get to to get to the
ieas Net Zero scenario so today's
report's really good news and it can
it's showing the building momentum but
there's still a lot more that needs to
be done to actually implement this and
and get all this capacity built on the
ground
well you mentioned speed there do you
have any reservations at all because it
is happening it's such a rapid speed
I mean to be perfectly honest with you
Vanessa what's happening is people
setting higher targets and you know we
continue to grow at a pretty good speed
but what's required for Net Zero
requires even more speed and everywhere
we still face a lot of issues around uh
planning and and bureaucracy and getting
things approved and the iea in its
report says that we could actually
increase uh the rate of deployment by 25
just by fixing uh some of these issues
around policy and regulation so we're
far from complacent because we know in
nearly every case for instance it takes
longer to permit an offshore Wind Farm
than it does to actually build it and
and things shouldn't be like that
obviously
so from your point of view then these
targets are realistic
I think they're realistic and I think
we've shown
um over the years that yeah Renewables
had a phenomenal growth both wind and
solo and we've consistently
um outperformed um people's predictions
but there's a lot of work that needs to
go into this uh to really make this
happen
um in time to be the solution that we
need to be for the climate crisis so I'm
pretty optimistic and I I'm I think our
whole industry stands ready to deliver
but there's a lot that needs to happen
to make this um to make this real and to
deliver on time
Ben thank you very much indeed has been
back for there speaking to me thank you
now also making climate news today
campaigners are calling on the
government to increase hedgerows by 40
by 2050. the charity cpres says more
Hedges would boost wildlife and climate
action
Hedges provide food and shelter for
animals birds and insects
the European Union has agreed a new law
guaranteeing products sold in the EU are
not linked to the destruction of forests
that's according to the UN an area
larger than the EU was lost to
deforestation globally between 1990 and
2020 with the European Union countries
responsible for around 10 percent of the
Lost
the new law will require all companies
to issue a due diligence statement in
order to sell products like coffee cocoa
and wood on the EU markets
and remember the host pipe ban well I
certainly do was some of them are still
in place would you believe but they're
being lifted Yorkshire water has become
the latest water supply to lift the ban
after recent rainfall refills reservoirs
there are still hose pipe bands they're
in plays in other areas Cornwall and
parts of Devon too
the cop-15 biodiversity Summit kicks off
in Montreal tomorrow with delegates from
across the world discussing the ways to
protect the Earth and animals and also
the ecosystems now environmental leaders
are calling for ambitious plans to
preserve the globe with a U.N
environment Chief warning that we are at
war with nature and we must make peace
but with no major world leaders due to
attend the Summers there are concerns
that the necessary commitments will not
be made will our science correspondent
Thomas Moore joins us now and Thomas
some Stark um warning there coming in
from the UN
foreign
is that across the planet the abundance
and variety of life is in free fall one
million species of plants and animals
are threatened with Extinction and it's
not just the loss of those creatures
that is causing alarm they are just the
symptom of an underlying crisis in
nature that that will also affect us
thus because nature provides us with a
clean water to to drink the the food to
eat the the air to breathe so that this
is something that is beginning to get
through to world leaders that this
really counts Nature's not just nice to
have it is essential it is our life
support and that's why here in these
very strong warnings from the United
Nations environment program however as
you say world leaders will not be there
and that is causing some dismay of
course they were queuing up to be seen
at the climate conference in Egypt but
this is going to be a lower key Affair
where it's going to be left to ministers
and delegates to thrash out this
essential blueprint on protecting
biodiversity trying to reverse that loss
of nature by 2030 not much time left but
this is something they're determined to
do so you're going to see some call to
protect 30 percent of the land and sea
area by 2030 to reduce pesticide use to
reduce the amount of deforestation
remove agricultural subsidies this kind
of really important stuff that pull it
all together will help nature survive
despite all those threats that include
changes from from human impacts but also
from climate change too it is reaching a
crunch point and the UN says we do need
to act now
absolutely Tom thank you
and that's always it from us today but
just a reminder that you can watch Tom
heaps climate show on Saturdays and
Sundays at 3 30 in the afternoon or at 7
30 in the evening
and if you have any questions about
climate change that you want answered
very simple just send those questions to
us using that QR code which is on your
screen right now and we'll try to answer
as many as we can on Tom's show
but for now that's it from me thanks for
watching have a lovely day bye for now